io sono andrea genovese sono molto
contento di essere qui e sono anche un
po emozionato devo dire sono emozionato
per due motivi uno è che ted
per chi si occupa di creatività di
comunicazione di condivisione della
cultura di nuove idee di innovazione è
veramente un icona è un punto di
riferimento importante le date del
palermo per me è il secondo motivo di
coinvolgimento perché sono in qualche
maniera legato affettivamente a questa
terra alla sicilia perché qui più di
cento anni fa è nato mio nonno mio nonno
viene dalla valderice nato più di cento
anni fa e un posto di fronte all'isola
di mozia dalla parte di trapani e quello
che vi voglio raccontare partendo dalle
sale non hanno a che fare con le
passioni con lo sviluppo delle
potenzialità delle persone e con diciamo
lo sviluppo del talento che è secondo me
il livello successivo
e dice volevo partire da questa terra e
del mio nonno perché il mio nonno più di
cento anni fa potete immaginare era la
fine della prima guerra mondiale si è
imbarcato clandestino e ha attraversato
l'oceano ed è arrivato ad ellis island
chi di voi è stato ad ellis island new
york sa che è quest'isola di fronte a
manhattan dove sbarcavano appunto gli
immigrati un po come gli immigrati che
stanno sbarcando in questo momento su
queste nostre isole insomma che in
qualche modo gridano democrazia noi
all'occidente
ebbene il mio nonno quindi è partito da
una situazione di difficoltà di disagio
di carenza come poteva essere l'italia
ma in particolare la sicilia alla fine
della prima guerra mondiale che
immaginate arriva a new york nel momento
in cui cioè la grande depressione e
quindi in realtà
fatica ma poi riesce a vivere una vita
piena e felice e quindi ad avere in
qualche modo successo
e lo ha fatto soprattutto
inseguendo le sue grandi passioni che
poi sotto nascondevano delle grandi
potenzialità
una delle grandi passioni che aveva mio
nonno era la curiosità e quindi in
qualche maniera
amava viaggiare amava il mare e questo
lo ha portato in giro per il mondo
un'altra grande passione era l'amore per
l'apprendimento e anche questa è una
potenzialità l'amore per l'apprendimento
e questo l'ho aiutato ad imparare le
lingue e ha lavorato per tantissime
compagnie di navigazione e questo quindi
gli ha consentito poi insomma veramente
di viaggiare il mondo a un certo punto
in questo lungo peregrinare per fortuna
si è fermata da qualche parte si è
fermato in cina shanghai e lì è contato
mia nonna e questa nonna e potete
immaginare una donna cinese che vive
ancora vive a roma in italia insomma
vicino a casa mia ea un nome
impronunciabile tanto che noi l'abbiamo
sempre chiamato chiamata nonna cina
perché in realtà lei si chiama assenza
un cin
quindi mia nonna sia nessun cin per noi
non scena allora potete immaginare
quindi in qualche maniera ci sono due
elementi di questa storia che a me
piacciono uno è un uomo che insegue le
sue passione in fondo scopre sviluppa le
sue potenzialità ea una vita ricca e di
successo e dall'altra e anche questo mix
di culture queste ibridazione questo
sangue misto che in qualche modo scorre
anche nelle mie vene e che è appunto la
cina e l'oriente e tutto l'immaginario
culturale estetico il sistema di valori
completamente diverso che in qualche
maniera ho ereditato questa cosa
in realtà soprattutto quando uno è
piccolo e ragazzino come si dice da noi
a roma è come dire non è una fonte di
ricchezza così come la scopri più tardi
ma è una fonte di confusione perché non
sai a quale modello fare riferimento
allora io credo che questi due elementi
la passione e in qualche modo legato
alle potenzialità e questo concetto di
mix di culture e di
ibridazione sono proprio due concetti
alla base di quello di creatività e la
creatività secondo me è una grandissima
potenzialità dell'uomo in questi ultimi
anni ho sviluppato moltissimo invece lo
studio di quello che poi è anche parte
di un mestiere che sto facendo ora che è
quello del coach quindi allo studio
delle potenzialità
lo studio
di come sviluppare le potenzialità di
come individuarle soprattutto nelle fasi
importanti nelle fasi in cui noi
scegliamo la nostra vocazione il nostro
percorso di studi in cui facciamo le
nostre scelte professionali come si fa a
portare una potenzialità fino a farla
diventare un talento c'è qualche cosa
che non ci aiuta a capire quali sono le
nostre potenzialità ea lavorare ma anche
solo a porre l'attenzione sulle nostre
potenzialità
innanzitutto c'è una cultura che si
concentra moltissimo sulle patologie
dell'uomo non si concentra sulle
potenzialità si concentra sui disturbi
solo negli ultimi anni c'è stata una
corrente soprattutto psicologica
d'oltreoceano che ha studiato invece le
potenzialità alle eccellenze perché
alcune persone riuscivano e soprattutto
ha tentato di capire
anche se alcuni disturbi alcuni problemi
delle persone erano in qualche maniera
legate a qualche cosa di invece di
potenziale che non veniva espresso
io voglio citare infatti a questo
proposito due persone che secondo me
sono molto importanti sono seligman e
peterson che hanno scritto un libro
bellissimo
qualche anno fa che si chiama appunto
psicologia positiva e loro hanno fatto
un lavoro di studio e di ricerca molto
interessante
in tutto il mondo e hanno alla fine
individuato 24 potenzialità comuni a
tutti gli esseri umani in tutti i popoli
alcuni queste potenzialità sono anche
quelle di mio nonno come ad esempio
l'amore per la conoscenza la curiosità e
la creatività ne ho qui portate alcune
proprio perché secondo me sono
interessante me ne leggo solo alcune
ovviamente l'hanno organizzata in sei
virtù in 6 macro virtù una virtù è la
saggezza la conoscenza e c'è la
curiosità quindi l'interesse per il
mondo l'amore per il sapere le capacità
critiche l'ingegnosità
l'intelligenza sociale ed emotiva la
lungimiranza c'è una seconda virtù che
invece è il coraggio e le potenzialità
sono il valore
l'audacia in qualche maniera la
perseveranza l'integrità c'è una terza
virtù che loro chiamano umanità o amore
e dentro chiaramente cella con la
cordialità la generosità la capacità di
amare e di lasciarsi amare ce n'è
un'altra che la giustizia all'interno
della quale si trovano le potenzialità
inaspettate uno sicuramente il senso
civico l'imparzialità l'equità ma anche
la leadership
e poi c'è la temperanza come virtù e
dentro c'è l'autocontrollo la prudenza
l'umiltà la modestia infine la
trascendenza e dentro la trascendenza ci
sono la capacità di apprezzare la
bellezza
dell'eccellenza la gratitudine la
speranza la spiritualità la capacità di
perdonare il senso dell'umorismo e la
vitalità la passione l'entusiasmo ora
quante persone realmente conoscete che
esprimono al cento per cento il loro
potenziale quante persone realmente
conoscete che sono come dire che hanno
sviluppato questo dono naturale o il
talento che hanno allora non tantissime
non tantissime e soprattutto per
probabilmente per due motivi un motivo e
la paura
è chiaramente la paura di sbagliare
anche qui c'è un cultura che soprattutto
qui in italia non non ti aiuta in un
premio l'errore non lo vede come una
medaglia all'esperienza cosa che invece
perché si sviluppa la silicon valley in
america ad esempio perché si riesce a
sviluppare un ecosistema che aiuta le
startup a crescere a nascere con un
tasso di mortalità elevatissimo perché
lì c'è una cultura che non demonizza
l'errore lo sbaglio e quindi in questo
caso il fallimento se voi fallite in
italia è molto difficile poi riuscire a
fare una impresa c'è tutto un sistema
legale fiscale e finanziario e non ti
aiuta quindi da una parte c'è
soprattutto anche quando studiavamo
insomma in qualche maniera
se noi prendevamo non so a me capitava
di prendere magari un 4 di matematica e
un 8 in greco e al però mi costringevano
in qualche maniera a lavorare sul 4 in
matematica quindi ancora in qualche
maniera tentavano di livellare cioè di
essere come dire di raggiungere quel
livello di mediocrità e non di lavorare
sulla parte che invece funziona va di
più a questo proposito sullo sviluppo
delle potenzialità e su come allenando
queste potenzialità si riesce ad
arrivare fino al talento c'è una teoria
interessante si chiama la teoria del
flop c'è questo
ricercatore che ha un nome talentoso si
chiama aziz michael è molto difficile
pronunciare però ha teorizzato
questo stato della mente particolarmente
interessante che appunto è il flow
quindi immaginate come dire questo asse
cartesiano in qualche maniera dove da
una parte ci sono le nostre capacità le
nostre potenzialità e dall'altra invece
ci sono gli obiettivi le sfide che noi
ci diamo allora non so ma immagino che
sarà capitato anche a voi che delle
volte siete in uno stato così di grande
stress no di grande ansia di grande
preoccupazione e altre volte invece
siamo in uno stato di apatia di noi sa a
volte anche di depressione e spesso
scegliamo fra questi due stati
ha tentato anche di capire le
motivazioni e ne fa un analisi e
ovviamente parziale limitata però aiuta
a capire e
allora che succede che se noi ci diamo
degli obiettivi troppo sfidanti rispetto
alle nostre capacità rispetto alle
nostre potenzialità siamo appunto in
quello che lui chiama uno stato di ansia
e di stress
se invece noi siamo spostati sulla delle
ascisse e quindi ci diamo degli
obiettivi piuttosto bassi abbiamo delle
capacità che non stiamo mettendo in
gioco delle potenzialità allora siamo in
qualche maniera annoiate e possiamo
anche diventare depresse
allora c'è uno stato invece ideale in
cui è appunto è il flow potremmo anche
tradurre come flusso ma flusso di
coscienza in qualche maniera ed è uno
stato lì c'è una citazione rocciatore
uno stato in cui noi perdiamo
completamente invece il senso del tempo
e dello spazio che ci sta intorno
ed è lo stato in cui
l'attività che stiamo svolgendo e
adeguata alle capacità e le potenzialità
che abbiamo appreso finora e quindi in
quel momento siamo completamente
assorbiti da quell attività è
sicuramente siamo come dire capaci di
ottenere anche una grande gratificazione
da quello che facciamo ed è una
gratificazione spesso interna quindi non
è qualche cosa che noi otteniamo come
risultato come riconoscimento
dall'esterno ma qualche cosa è un
livello di piacere che ci arriva
dall'interno
perché non è neanche un livello di
eccitazione ma troppo un livello di
gratificazione questa cosa si può
provare anche facendo delle attività non
particolarmente sfidante o competitive
magari leggendo un libro magari
ascoltando un brano musicale suonando
uno strumento o comunque svolgendo
un'attività anche un ragazzino davanti
alla playstation e nel pieno
dell'utilizzo delle sue capacità in quel
caso allora c'è un
modo per riuscire a portare queste
potenzialità fino al livello del talento
ed è soprattutto quello di lavorare
gradualmente
per fissando degli obiettivi
come dire gradualmente sempre più
sfidanti ma soprattutto allenando le
nostre potenzialità
le nostre capacità ora accade una cosa
in effetti che è molto
tipica che si chiama ciclo della
rinuncia accade quando in qualche
maniera questi obiettivi sono troppo
sfidanti e noi stiamo in una situazione
di stress la cosa immediata che ci viene
da fare è eliminare quell'obiettivo non
perseguirlo più non provare più a
raggiungere può essere un obiettivo che
riguarda qualsiasi aspetto della nostra
vita la competence le relazioni e le
amicizie l'amore è piuttosto che la
nostra identità e che cosa otteniamo nel
momento in cui eliminiamo questo
obiettivo otteniamo subito un vantaggio
ma siamo rilassati non abbiamo più quel
livello di ansia che avevamo prima
però appunto come risultato negativo
abbiamo il fatto che
entriamo in uno stato di apatia e che
probabilmente molti noi hanno
sperimentato soprattutto chi fa dei
lavori creativi o che fa dei progetti
per cui ci sono i momenti di grande
intensità di grande stress di consegna
di sviluppo di creatività di
elaborazione e poi invece ci sono dei
momenti morti tra virgolette
e allora c'è
come dire un lavoro che si può fare in
qualche maniera una delle tecniche
quella del coaching appunto che quello
appunto di fissare degli obiettivi che
hanno senso il significato per noi è di
allenare le nostre capacità delle nostre
competenze gradualmente per arrivare
fino a sviluppare il talento
ora non vorrei concludere questa cosa
parlando appunto di un progetto che a
che fare con con l'apprendimento perché
tutto questo a che fare con
l'apprendimento chiaramente che l'unica
capacità che dobbiamo riuscire a tenere
allenata tutta la vita in ogni momento
ea questo proposito velocità re un
intervento che è stato fatto alla pelle
americana da questo serre che anne
robinson è di origine inglese però vive
da qualche anno in america e sta
portando sta riformando quasi tutti i
modelli didattici di quel paese e lui
parla della rivoluzione l'apprendimento
e in questo video sulla ted americano in
cui parla della rivoluzione momento dice
questa frase incontro una miriade di
persone che non sono appassionate di ciò
che fanno semplicemente trascorrono la
loro vita tirando avanti non traggono un
grande piacere da quel che fanno lo
sopportano piuttosto che goderselo e
aspettano che arrivi il weekend ma
incontro anche persone che amano quello
che fanno e non riescono a immaginare di
fare qualcos'altro 16 loro lascia stare
fai altro si domandano di chi stai
parlando
perché non è quello che fanno
ma è quello che sono dicono ma questo
sono io sarebbe da matti per me
abbandonarlo perché esprime il me stesso
più autentico
ecco io vorrei chiudere
come dire citando un progetto che sto
per per lanciare per avviare che si
chiama social accademiche a che fare
proprio con l'apprendimento con una
nuova tecnica di apprendimento la social
accademy vuole essere un'accademia i
talenti quindi secondo me non è
sufficiente perdano 20 minuti per
condividere come dire le idee e le
opinioni più interessanti poi ci vuole
un lavoro ci vuole l'incontro e spesso
le persone di talento i cosiddetti due
quelli che vi realmente sono impegnate
ai loro progetti non hanno tempo per
insegnare o per scrivere libri o per
fare conferenze e allora io vorrei
partire da questa accademia i talenti da
questa social academy e perché con una
visione che è il mondo sarebbe un posto
migliore se tutti avessero gli strumenti
e le conoscenze per sviluppare le
proprie potenzialità il proprio talento
grazie